this is what it looks like when the
coronavirus restrictions are back long
lines have formed outside the testing
facilities in the district of goethe
slaw the new restrictions here and in
neighboring varlyn DAF took effect at
midnight the mass testing follows a huge
corona virus outbreak at Toni's
slaughterhouse where more than 1500
workers have contracted kovat 19 now
some 600,000 people are affected by the
restrictions Goethe slows mert old DW
he's furious I'm angry with a company of
10 years I'm angry with the system
behind of it and anger is the system of
sub sub sub contractors which is totally
an entrenched in transparent people had
to put up with long waits to get tested
I want to get tested and do my bit to
help find out whether we're all infected
here in good as low or not we want to
travel to Bavaria on Saturday and the
condition is to present a negative
coronavirus test that's our gold today
indeed with summer vacation about to
begin
officials in popular destinations like
Bavaria say good as no residents are not
welcome unless they show proof of
testing negative for the virus
neighboring Austria has gone even
further targeting germany's most
populous state our neighbor germany with
its state of north rhine-westphalia has
shown how quickly the situation can turn
dramatic we were therefore forced to
issue a level 5 travel warning for that
state we hope of course that the
situation there will quickly improve and
that there won't be a further spread
across germany alternatively to see of
that decision snail base it overall
numbers are still low in Germany but the
latest local outbreaks are causing
concern the meat processing industry in
particular is under pressure employees
living conditions are being blamed for
the spread of the virus 23 workers have
tested positive at the visa North plant
Germany's biggest poultry plant where
mass testing of over a thousand
kurz got underway today let's have a
look at this with Christian Lind Meyer
who speaks for the World Health
Organization and joins us from Geneva
welcome to DW but what do you make of
German efforts to control this a new
outbreak well thanks for having me
what's it's a typical scenario where you
don't have communities spread in the
whole country anymore but we have now a
cluster case is next year big large
cluster of cases and here to test and
trace basically every single person to
offer tests for everybody is a really
good idea because this is how you find
out where the virus is how many people
have the virus who the contacts are and
this is the best way to contain it so
this sort of locally controlled lockdown
rather than being control from the
center you think this is what we're
going to have to get used to this is
actually what we should aim for then
instead of having a community spread
which we don't cannot oversee where the
virus is we will have to work on trying
to get the response so strong and so
strict and testing so so strict and
surveillance that we can respond to
individual clusters individual cases
immediately ideally notice later that we
have 1200 or more cases like now but
earlier than that and then contain those
cases and maybe lock down an individual
place maybe only have a city or town on
the strong stronger measures rather than
having the whole country to go into a
lockdown scenario that is most likely
something we will have to look forward
for the future but actually have to work
forward to right meet processing plants
have been at the center of a two
outbreaks here in Germany and two in the
United States in May does the meat
processing industry have a coronavirus
problem the way we see this right now
and we don't have to full information
about the conditions there were what the
living conditions the working conditions
were so it seems rather than it has to
do with a combination of factors there
the fact that it is a certain species of
our certain type of factory it's it it
looks like it's rather the the
combination of yeah again living
conditions working conditions and the
fact that in a closed environment people
can easily transmit the virus from one
person to the other that's something
which has three control other sort of
branches don't have that same scenario
in their working environment of course
other companies have to put out a plan
on how to enable even coming back to
work and how their workers can go back
to offices so that is a very different
scenario then it's very strict and very
strong strongly drink like recommended
business okay and just looking ahead
that w-h-o is warning that the global
number of covered 19 cases could reach
10 million next week what does our
future look like we'll numbers and
deaths just keep rising until a vaccine
is developed but globally the figures
are rising let's not forget that only in
Central Europe we have a lot of couple
of countries which have declining cases
over the global we reach one peak after
the other and yes you will be most
likely ten million next week so until we
have a treatment first of all until we
have a scenario where every country can
trace and find and survey every single
case and have a better control of the
virus in their country we will most
likely see rising cases on a weekly
basis that is not the best scenario but
of course we will have to deal with this
and have to avoid more and more people
coming back with virus once they get
infected somewhere else so I said it's a
long journey it's not it's mother short
sprint it's a marathon where I thank you
for joining us so Christine linnemeier
from the World Health Organization thank
you much let me bring you up to speed
with some other developments in this
pandemic India has registered 16,000 new
cases its highest ever daily increase
and the government has called in the
army to manage new treatment facilities
in Delhi
the EU may ban travelers from the United
States Brazil and Russia when it reopens
its external borders according to the
New York Times and New York and Berlin
have canceled marathons due to
coronavirus concerns